(metal spatulas striking pans)
(pans sizzling)
- This sound is quite a music to our ears.
- We just stepped out of
the car, you can hear,
There's like, literally,
from this street corner,
an entire like cloud of
smoke rising into the air.
You can her the clanking
of the metal spatulas.
We are here to eat taka tak.
And this what an atmosphere,
what an environment.
Oh man, this is just smoke therapy.
- The sound is music
to our ears literally.
(car horn)
- And the smoke is
aromatherapy to our noses.
This is amazing.
You would definitely think
there is a fire happening
in the neighborhood from
this amount of smoke.
Look at that.
(metal spatulas striking pans)
- Oh man.
- I don't even know if you can hear me,
but this is unbelievable.
The steam, the smoke is
just pouring out of that...
Oh wow, smoke in the eyes, some chillis.
But the clanking, I can barely...
yeah, this is absolutely incredible.
They are mashing up the spices,
they're mashing up the...
Whoa, it feels like I am in a volcano.
- Mark, are you crying from happiness?
Are these tears of happiness?
- Tears of happiness
and chillis to the eyes
- Tears of happiness, exactly.
(upbeat rock music)
(metal spatulas striking pans)
- That is for sure the most
musical food, and the loudest,
and the steamiest, some of the
most amazing food environment
I have ever seen, and
what you have to do is,
you have to choose our organs.
Self service organs.
- Not our organs, those organs.
(laughter)
- Okay, yes, you're right about that.
You just grab it with your fingers?
- [Guide] Yeah, whatever you want.
- [Mark] So, you got some
kidneys, you got some testicles.
This one looks enticing.
- [Guide] We also have brain here.
- [Mark] Brain testicles.
These are kidneys right.
- [Guide] Yes.
- [Mark] How many kidneys?
One more testicle.
- [Guide] Let's make a pair.
(laughter)
- [Mark] Lets make a pair.
Then we got some brains here.
- [Guide] Yeah.
- [Mark] Oh yeah.
Okay, we got brains,
kidneys, and testicles.
I love how you just grab your organs
and then stick it into a bowl.
(laughs) This is amazing.
(upbeat rock music)
So, we chose our organs,
you bring it to one
of the stations, one of
the clanking stations.
Wow, my ears are starting to ring.
There he is about to make our order.
(pan hisses)
(upbeat rock music)
Woo, this is without
a doubt of of the most
intense restaurants, intense
cooking, intense dishes,
I have ever seen anywhere in the world.
The production here is just mind blowing.
And it literally feels
like you are in the middle
of a volcano when you are standing here.
It is...my ears are ringing,
my eyes are burning.
This is food on the next level.
(stall operator talking
in foreign language)
Roll it? How should I?
Okay, take a piece.
This is tandoori roti.
Pick up a piece of the
roti itself and then...
- [Stall Operator] Naan.
- [Mark] It's naan?
- [Mark] Oh, it's naan, okay.
- [Stall Operator]
Tandoori Pakistani naan.
- [Mark] Oh, it's so hot.
Oh, it's like padi chilli.
Wow.
It's so good.
All of those organs
just melt in your mouth.
It's so hot.
The way it is all mashed up perfectly,
the chillis, the tomatoes,
everything is mashed up perfectly.
The spices, you can
taste the cumin in there.
Oh man, it's salty, it's slightly organy.
- More.
- Wow, that is so good, it's so...
You can taste the grainy
pieces of the brain in there,
and the like, irony pieces of the kidney.
Oh man, that is just
like, an organ to like.
An organ to like, and
orchestra of organ to like.
(talking in foreign language)
- Amazing.
- I don't know if you could
hear anything I explained
on camera describing, all I
wana say is that was amazing.
Everything is so perfectly mashed up
and the way they mash it
up they're such artists.
They are so skillful.
The chefs are just doing amazing things.
Yeah, that style, that
skill, that experience,
that taka tak.
(talking in foreign language)
Thank you.
(upbeat rock music)
That's possibly the most intense.
I think I've inhaled some serious smoke.
Back in the car, that taka
tak brains and testicles
and kidney experience was
one of the most intense foods
and cooking techniques
that I've ever seen.
They are so skillful, they're
so good at what they do,
and that is an incredibly delicious dish.
Like, every single piece of
pepper, tomato, spice, testicle,
kidney, everything is
like micro little pieces,
and everything is mixed
completely finely thorough.
Every bite taste exactly the same because
it's mixed so fine.
Yeah, incredibly delicious,
my ears are slightly ringing,
my eyes are burning, very very happy.